this brings me to uh a topic that most
people don't know about
the wealthiest of the world know all
about this uh there's something called
tax loss
harvesting and we recently saw a report
come out
i think it's pro-publica did it where
they got access to the tax returns of
very very wealthy people
and i don't remember the exact numbers
but it was like less than four percent
income taxes what they were paying now
people that's the headline everyone
yells and screams whatever uh
we should caveat like wealthy people
don't make most of their money from
income they make it from capital gains
and other types of
wealth generation events and most of
their wealth is in a unrealized
gain uh kind of status therefore they
don't pay taxes until they actually sell
it or monetize or whatever
but they also understand this idea of
tax loss harvesting so maybe describe
what exactly is tax loss harvesting and
then we could talk about how that
applies to crypto and what you guys are
doing with it i think it's the most
hidden treasure in wealth generation
that there is i think most people know
wealth is generated by assets it's by
equity ownership it's by owning things
that appreciate
but when you own assets unfortunately
everything isn't linear up into the
right
is up and to the right over time with
dips along the way and so what's not
talked about enough
is how taking advantage of those dips
selling harvesting a loss and then
legally repurchasing your position back
in at the right time in order to
continue to appreciate over the long
term
that's tax loss harvesting and so as you
do that all of those losses start to
accumulate and losses carry forward
you can't carry them back so losses
today are better than losses tomorrow
harvest them anytime you can and you
keep stacking them people talk about
stacking sats and bitcoin
stack losses and then when you
ultimately do convert to fiat
not that you should in crypto as
bitcoin's gonna rule the world right um
but when you do you have this whole you
know treasure chest of losses that
offset capital gains
almost entirely if you do it right and
so in that article i was a big fan of
reading that but that was the one piece
that wasn't talked about was
even when these people these wealthy
individuals do cash back to fiat
that's why you're seeing such small
percentages four percent five percent
is they've harvested losses along the
way so forget crypto for a second if
this was just the regular stock market
and let's say i bought a stock at
ten dollars uh it goes up to fifteen
dollars and then all of a sudden it goes
back down to eight dollars
uh and i actually sell the stock at
eight dollars
i book a two dollar loss right and so if
i then got paid two dollars at work as
part of income or whatever i basically
could
negate the two dollars of income with
the two dollars of
the loss from the investment basic over
generalization
now in the equity market there's all
sorts of rules around wash trading which
basically means i can't go
sell the stock and then immediately buy
it right back there's a period of time i
can't
actually own the stock and it makes it a
little bit harder to do this
in the equity market in the crypto
market though those rules don't apply
uh as of now maybe they will in the
future but right now they don't apply
that's correct they apply to securities
cryptocurrency's property right now
and so it's not a loophole i think it's
a known item it's
uh going to come up in the in the future
it's a you know low agenda item right
now there's still this whole
infrastructure behind cryptocurrency and
a movement happening
where we're going to see a lot and but
here's the thing in the equity world
what the most savvy people are doing is
they're not waiting 30 days to
repurchase their position in their asset
they're repurchasing a position in a 95
correlated asset
immediately holding that during the
30-day wait period
and then going back into their original
asset so software does that software can
run all these correlations and
statistical regression tables
tax bits doing this in preparation you
know for watch cell rules on both
we're not just a cryptocurrency company
anymore we support commodities and
equities and this whole gamut of assets
um but that's the power there is you can
start to get creative
especially in crypto like how many types
of bitcoin are there bitcoin rap
bitcoin um you know so many different
things that are tied to the price of
bitcoin
that's going to help to get around watch
the rules in the event that those ever
do apply
and so what do you guys do with tax loss
harvesting today like how can i use
taxbix software either as a retail user
or through an enterprise
product for tax loss harvesting yeah let
me tell you about it so let's start on
the consumer side any
one of uh cryptocurrency investors right
now can go sign up at taxbid.com
do it yourself link your exchange
accounts you're gonna have this whole
tax optimization module you're going to
be able to go in there
and see all of your outstanding cost
basis lots that sum up to what you own
and you're going to see them by
source where they're being stored what
exchanges etc wallets
and you can start to see okay now as of
right now
i have a loss and this lot i should
select that lot go and sell it
um you're gonna see the software update
real time and and you know decrease your
taxable gains or take you to a lost
position
and start to accumulate those losses and
so you can do that across
all the platforms that you hold assets
in uh through taxbit consumer
where we're going and lots of
announcements that i'm excited to share
is
you're not going to have to use taxbid
consumer for much longer
we have an amazing list of clients that
we're actively
implementing right now dozens where the
same platforms that you're using on a
day-to-day basis through your mobile
apps
you're gonna be able to do this natively
within their application tax center tabs
are coming to the industry and it's an
end-to-end experience to be able to
harvest losses straight on those
platforms
and set notifications set automated
trades and alerts
and so many other things and so we're
excited to share more in some way
uh shopify's entire motto is like arm
the rebels
right there's no greater rebel than the
bitcoin and kind of cryptocurrency
industry
and so really what you guys are doing is
you're trying to take these very
sophisticated strategies
these uh in many cases complex
computational
um kind of technologies that have been
built for the ultra rich
and you're now trying to almost bring
that to uh the everyday retail user
whether it's they go directly to tax bit
or they're gonna eventually at some
point be able to use it in actual
uh exchanges or wallets that they use on
a day-to-day basis that's exactly right
and i'm
we're democratizing tax usually you need
to go and pay an attorney or a you know
cpa
and they do this for wealthy individuals
how can we bring this to the masses so
every day people
can harvest losses it's not hundreds of
thousands of dollars but you know tens
or hundreds of dollars that is most
more typical in america today for middle
america yeah
is there anything else that you see that
people who are
interested in reducing tax bills that
like a wealthy strategy that they should
be thinking about here in crypto
and that's much more like an advice
standpoint but like tax loss harvesting
is a great idea
right are there other things that you
guys have either built into the product
or you think that people should be aware
of
so there's a variety of ways to harvest
losses and
you know selling is one of them but
cryptocurrency
ultimately we want it to have utility as
a currency vehicle and
spending is a taxable event and so when
you think about actually using crypto
there are ways that you can use crypto
to optimize your taxes in a tax
beneficial way similar to loss
harvesting
but also donate for those that are
charitable minded out there
donations are one of the most uh
fascinating topics that so many high net
worth people do
because everything that you donate is
tax free from a capital gain perspective
if you're in a long-term status all of
that you get credit for a charitable
deduction at the fair market value at
the time you donated it
and it is tax-free and so you're double
dipping from the charitable contribution
and the tax-free on the appreciation so
we're helping a lot of people on the
charity side and then as well the tax
loss harvesting side by either
selling or using crypto